oh no I forgot I got Karen laughs Karen
I see with the carries it's like a drag
once you get the taste of that sweet air
name this is gonna be a long time for
turn ups in the other bag it's Tom
you will be Thomas a lot of paint effort
has gone into me oh you have to purchase
them with turnips
no [ __ ] way it can't be the zombie
Superman oh you have to push it
what's turnips is that like totally
pants hey
turnips isn't a vegetable it's like the
thing in Mario 2 that you pour the
grated thought people I think uh
fantastics I think anyway and so we get
a few to pick room come on I wanted to
be I guess I'll be Steve Ben I wanted to
be a million oh wait I can be the alien
I'm bailing
I can choose hats best game ever oh no
no no no now all the fun has been drain
out of the game oh no I can't I have to
purchase the bag ever you have to
purchase get dammit what is up with all
these microtransaction gonna get a
pattern ups now I okay stuff is
happening more paint action I love it
Wow Wow
I activated it Oh get a good ketchup of
course that don't be silly
but you like my head Ken a jelly ooh
I'll turn it face sign up for those
turnips I hope so cuz I'm getting that
[ __ ] hang my turn up get the [ __ ]
away it upset my Jenna
we're so fast oh but you're not dead up
360 emoji look at this 360 is that damn
I almost died Geist on you yeah
turn it up whoa what the [ __ ] what is
that oh whoa you have a couch my musics
playing man
oh it's coming after us
hi can you screw the turnips you just
have to save yourself this is like Star
Wars oh wait I just done man use all my
turnips
no there's still air how many do you
have
eight oh [ __ ] you maybe you have eleven
[ __ ] can you sighs turn to pray no
Jeevan do you even turn up to breath do
you even just why are they sliding away
are there turnips over here or did you
leave those now I took them okay I guess
we all each get our own trip then so
fairly yeah you can't die this is all
that you stopped up well don't get my
[ __ ] turnips then okay fifteen [ __ ]
you
twenty-five [ __ ] we even get her own
turnips and yeah turn it on skin and get
me and you have more okay I'll take the
top watch out for these Jason Jason guys
okay just do me my life I'm like almost
dead after just that really I just as
like a crusader is everyone knows that
I'm allergic
yeah just play that a game like this
okay so we got a push the Brad [ __ ] on
the barrels
shoot shoot barrels spam it it's not
worth no don't you die get the turnips
okay whoa ken I want you to get out of
here lamb is no George's okay oh my god
oh we made it
oh we made it okay okay where we've made
it with the light yay I got achievements
oh there's a slap okay I'm a glob now
come here let me slap the [ __ ] out of
you doesn't work the final but I'm
eating your brother shouldn't know
nothing okay oh okay so do I use the
slide
all right how does this light work do I
hug them to death is that it
wait oh let me I'll get my madigan girl
let me have it
okay Megan [ __ ] you [ __ ] I'm gonna hug
you so [ __ ] hard I'm hugging you so
good right now are you gonna die any
second son its oh man you're so dead
your order try I'm try to hack how do i
click that okay they said I did that
you're welcome I appreciate it man
I'm hugging them from a distance oh man
they're all dead thanks to my hugs okay
okay so telekinesis hug I'll hold it you
go oh I got a hug you [ __ ] pig man
yeah piggy
hey pity right Daisy oh wait nevermind
right D get you a piggy
you did it piggy you're coming up they
gave me human shield
oh no it doesn't work help oh [ __ ] I
almost died I had literally almost
telekinesis hags there's health up there
oh [ __ ] stay there piggy and be a nice
piggy I love you piggy all right I can
almost afford something cool I think
hey piggy the health thing is an
illusion it doesn't work unless like how
do I take them that in it's it all a lie
I'm shooting my energy into piggies bit
that's his face look happy about it so
very
contempt piggy all right
so what's this triangle thing scented up
is that custard sir all right let me put
piggy there okay another piggy don't
worry I got you back okay and then we
can bring you our number one [ __ ] piggy
with this oh no that doesn't work
oh wait this way all right how do we all
know it's electric yeah
god dammit I gotta get the gloves again
oh [ __ ] all right let's just be quick
this time what the [ __ ] are you doing to
my ass sir hey it is bacon sorry number
one piggy number two piggy now oh he's
not a sexy slightly less attractive can
you kick it a pig can the pig blotter
lasers of course what do you think
they're for burning his phaser it's
again so beautiful you won't tell a
difference even with me hey I say Nile
is the same she's not very happy about
that
yay stage 3 I was really longing for
this one I don't have to have a gloves
anymore I kind of look like a creeper by
the way I don't know if you noticed hey
dude these are looking a penis look what
pretty good you look like a penis with
hair on it I'm done your [ __ ] together
I didn't MLG 360 and then yeah there you
got MLG that [ __ ] alright you'll never
get us now worried emoji I did it
did you wash a oh no it's not dead hey
more did you see that 360p so good
wait do I have to okay is it open I
think it's time so we got a hurry it's
not like I can but yeah you're so bad I
don't know
oh god is it's barrels
get Tim fruits and vegetables are very
important to your done for you but not
for relish
Thanks really thank you both
you're the best they're so deadly it's
like a like a Bible game with like good
messages and [ __ ] eat all your
vegetables bad guys I know the evil
robots will well finish hey I gotta get
all the turnips Pratt I'm gonna get gum
going for that hat if done luck that hat
maybe the Nelson ninja that I'm going
for I'm okay with being an ugly creeper
as long as I get a suite at time you
didn't see the hats
okay the Hat selections were pretty
[ __ ] good it's all about have any
media turn up so you need to get at what
[Music]
I don't know I lost count but I would
say a hundred maybe I lost count out of
this county yes
don't you count your turnips bro
everyone has their turnips
why did turn it looks like poke balls
man fine no trouble why did we never
realized I just gotta catch them all oh
yeah of course you gotta catch all the
turnips and 360 MMOG through your way my
aunt tells me you go for I say capacity
code capacitors room my turn up shot the
electricity oh [ __ ] I took some damage
don't you die I won't oh god I might die
hey okay so many turnips protect you I
can't take them cuz they're all dead
electricity
dad damn it it pains me so much no no
this game is [ __ ] hardcore l-like I
can't even take it this music it's just
like speaking okay it's fixed to me I
get so teary-eyed it's so beautiful I
get teary-eyed seeing all these turnips
go into ways
I'm gonna do you have naps 70-72 [ __ ]
you baby 133 pretty good job what the
[ __ ] you [ __ ]
can we get a hand before you I'm gonna
get all the [ __ ] turnips
don't worry I'll just the pie stage
there's paw oh they share the pie
whatever Oh a lot don't step back this
could be dangerous
okay you feed their pious soros we're
gonna power up oh sorry
I need it we need it I wish I could
sprint cuz Colby share them oh I'm a
chef now
great go I [ __ ] know it spice they're
coming from my anus it's a list of those
what am I doing with them they hope the
buttons there was this dude no they
don't oh it's a pie Sara's in my guy eat
the pie all right okay I make him go on
the button dysentery she likes it
yeah no no no he got it right yeah okay
so smart
oh I guess I'll keep [ __ ] out pies
huh all these turnips how many do you
have now
74 five in 7h3 [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] wait what
happens if we're both standing here
nothing okay oh hey he's not following
you we need him to both sides because
I'm not doing my job with the turnips
got a poop white custards let's just
plates it's custards customers of Cour
he loves Custer's he'd better watch out
the solidity Tubby's look at him
don't worry I'll see you'll go through
okay
oh wait don't worry I have the slides I
have it can we bring it
shield me oh god I'm so slow Hellboy
Kevin please screw the turnips I need
your help
there's got it I took damage I'm
shooting tap out PP help help me Ken I
think
shotgun better this sucks captivate how
many custards piggy I got him I know
he's the sexy woman before we had the
face melt off one now we have this sexy
one okay thank you based piggy for
letting us use you for melting off our
face so we can proceed okay that bread
here
oh sorry sorry I really don't want to
redo this I think we just have to know
[Music]
you just got yeah all right well I guess
we're gonna have to go back okay so that
means that someone else has to get the
the pie you have to get the pie it's
nicest oh wow leet snipe quickscope bro
yeah 360 pretty cool oh man you have you
have future an MMOG
this music gives me power okay
house it's Amer on it you should make it
Mont I should [ __ ] them seven quick
sips okay where is the pie sorry sir I
don't know I think it's over here no
wait where do you go oh yeah I still got
the laser gun - OH
can't be stopped and you're like [ __ ]
killing machine right now I don't see
him
white Oh God we're gonna have to look
for him oh my god he [ __ ] left us he
despawned it no he's like that you think
I got all my weight maybe if I hit this
one you'll come down let's see oh you
could leave us you later Beach oh my god
you what you left them over there so now
he's gonna you should come it's a pie
this is it right chef here yeah okay
well they'll call it a [ __ ] cake then
gone come here come here
kitty [ __ ] oh wait oh no wonder he was
gonna [ __ ] murder him he probably
brought in the other type - you're gonna
[ __ ] 360's man you gotta control
yourself follow me
well you got a place to custard as a
custard right there open your one ah you
have one eye [ __ ] you
jelly I'm up my hat did you jelly over
the Hat that I'm gonna buy with all my
[ __ ] turn upset you made you have
lady [ __ ]
81 Oh
that's right Pollock is he took it from
him he didn't drop one how do I know you
probably took it out for you Steve
piggy don't you hear piggy okay yeah
yeah like I don't have a lot of life so
if we die now I have like a little bitty
sliver oh yeah me too
okay thank you say gay okay then no no
no okay okay it's going back it's okay
okay Koopman I don't know I don't like
this place egg custard okay okay where
is he I can't see him right now he's not
he's not crossed yet [ __ ] out some more
custer's then [ __ ] it's okay okay now
okay okay
more custards come on you hungry little
piece of Gator oh the big occasion you
get the [ __ ] out of my way [ __ ] to
space yes best game ever
we did it Oh bumps for hats okay you
know what I was just about to say this
game cannot get any better but hold me
[ __ ]
alright hey push the button what a duh
okay okay we got to hurry up okay okay I
did it I took both of them go Chad I'm
going going going
mm-hmm okay you know what's coming for
you [ __ ] my turn Mike yes okay I'd do
it anyway sorry
promise you'll have that one if you oh
[ __ ] nevermind oh [ __ ] I almost died
okay oh thank you so kind you're welcome
[ __ ]
you gotta tell ya did he take it
oh go right go right go right yeah but I
gotta get the Turner say it okay I'm
getting the piggy thing okay yeah I
don't have anything I have to hold this
one down for you I think oh you have to
come here now wait put one in here for
me maybe I don't know okay oh god oh god
I'm dead I'm gonna go into teleporter go
in the teleporter
I couldn't what the [ __ ] I think I think
you have to bring a piggy around to me
no I that's impossible I can't can't do
cuz it opens it opens my gate up so it's
gotta be something that but I can just
place a piggy down yeah that's for your
side now Mossad I have to go little
disco on your side first then but we
both have to go to each you listen to me
shut up [ __ ] it's my custards and suck
it it's no custard guys Oh God oh you
scrub a scrub 92 custards 85 95 85 o-360
best game no it didn't feel true I'm
sorry
I felt like too much of Allah I'm just
kidding some oh god I keep forgetting it
oh god no I forgot no yeah [ __ ]
oh what a dumb laugh hey [ __ ] you that's
my laugh let's make it fun I'm shut up
oh alright
pay attention now you [ __ ] okay I was
talking to myself
I gotta get chi minh holy [ __ ] Lily this
game ever all right
screw the turnips okay let's have a
current turnips truth okay
Oh custard or whatever the [ __ ] up all
right you I don't have that much time
you know yeah but I'm leaving a timer
thing for you it's just great picking
breather here oh [ __ ] oh [ __ ] how the
[ __ ] am I gonna do that no okay well I
think you were right though
I just have to sneak through course I
was right who you think I am I don't
know why but this game ain't reminds me
of crash bandicoot yeah kind of it maybe
it's the music it's the music yeah and
it's kind of funny good ass this playful
ever look kind of like this where's
court exit and his name here oh yeah I'm
again oh yeah that moment we oh god oh
god
no no no no no no I still have 95
everybody won oh no I'm letting you
catch up yeah yeah burn your ass so you
get for taking my [ __ ] turnips so
greedy you don't [ __ ] touch my
turnips okay look at you gotta get
you're good you're ready you're they're
shooting Gordon why would I wait for you
[ __ ]
Oh Deb Tufte get the [ __ ] out of my way
you turn a [ __ ] know that I'm at the
top okay oh I didn't know that okay oh
god oh god oh god oh god oh baby yeah ii
don't open yet
okay [ __ ] ass let me I could shoot I
need to go in and take the solarbeam
then take the thing and then save the
world oh god I took damage so greedy for
turn s okay oh my god I forgot I forgot
goddamn it heard okay I get that you
said that's so country I feel like you
live here it's the counter music I can't
help it
the band here okay the plan is really
dumb
what the [ __ ] oh god oh god oh I've got
so many turnips so tempted no you
[ __ ]
okay I hope it anytime live it's really
hard I don't know if this we're supposed
to do I think you're supposed to go into
teleporter maybe wait I bet I can shoot
through the lasers and probably kill
that guy that's getting you oh yeah try
that you're gonna have to stand on it
all the time
you [ __ ] yeah you're right you're right
alright I'd [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ]
[ __ ] [ __ ]
oh god I'm god oh god oh god oh god no I
get so greedy for the turnips I got was
[ __ ] one one turnip feels totally
worth okay I'll stop I'm sorry yes you
okay can you get to teleport it what if
we both get through okay I'm gonna die
I'm gonna die
no darn Ives we okay it's okay okay so
both death appeal a teleporter you were
right the whole time hmm and I'm sorry
again I'm sorry I dad the turnip master
hey that's why I have the title occasion
shut up don't ever doubt me again [ __ ]
you think this title belt come with
nothing okay
you think this is all good licks no it's
turnips
is it good looks Oh got too many wine I
got it oh I had to I had to leave three
turnips ken do you understand the
sacrifice the sacrifice
thank God okay [ __ ] it teleport you
sorry you [ __ ]
yeah I guess I got you murdered how many
turnips oh we have a hundred and six
okay
you're forget Oh completely that's my
fault I went a literate arted
hey hey hurts so much I guess I'll bet
we're like literally the only one to
actually give a [ __ ]
[Music]
okay I'm ready I got I got it this one
there oh god that was so close
okay come on you can do it we need the
pig we need the pig do we really well
[ __ ] it's really [ __ ] hard okay we
still have to have the pig after all
that yeah how many cuts there's yeah
Sears hundred and ten 131 what why do
you think I play this game okay all
right I'm down I [ __ ] time down okay
turnips but how the [ __ ] am I gonna get
the piggy no wait no wait there's yummy
sound okay you [ __ ] come on come on we
know that now look I knew it before and
you just [ __ ] it and went into it I'm a
scientist I'm like green [ __ ] I made
you I made you I am your father you said
that I see with the Carrey's it's like a
drag where'd you get the taste of that
sweeter name this could be a montage
turn up some the elder man it's we're
making this so much harder
[Laughter]
Oh God okay this it's not that hard
don't get greedy for ten ups so we turn
up I don't know what a turn up is but it
looks like a pokeball and I [ __ ] what
all of them
oh no now I see the little thing in the
left corner that is a picture of a
turnip it's a rare radish that's what we
call it in Swedish I think a radish yes
is that what it is Friday or is there
something else that's right yes radish
it is right yeah it's not a [ __ ] turn
up the turn up is a lie come on come on
come on I'm hurrying I got it I got it
you didn't you [ __ ]
yeah I don't know I don't know did you
kill me I think I did I know I don't
think I did I didn't know I couldn't I
don't know if you can deny of it and I
we should exit this game no actually
when we've done we buy sweeta hats and
never play this game again okay deal
there's all terms over here
because they'll come after you at the
beginning I know that's my plug in a
minute I'm gonna make it turn ABS no
okay we see this getting money oh that's
so tired of these [ __ ] level it's the
music that starts over every time well I
don't mind anything dude I have such a
turnips advantage it's not even fair you
know I go here and purpose so they like
well imma let it know the level and I
can get these turnips there's so many oh
well it is you made it yeah okay we can
do this this time all right going the
teleporter okay I'm coming I'm coming
it's [ __ ] going the teleporter I mean
that's top order well you almost kill me
[ __ ] this is mine
now I can't pick it up
oh no no you [ __ ]
you too you too dad it wouldn't matter
okay we can do it oh don't shoot me
don't shoot me oh yes I do but he spins
on ax oh my god it's right [ __ ] here
you know what game ever I feel that I
felt that sweet [ __ ] hats man let's
get here let's go home let's go home
does it say you know I'm going home yeah
it went so fast my body was left behind
if I could give you a half hour right
now thanks for playing the whole game oh
my god
getting brothers what is the point of
buying [ __ ] hats [ __ ] you man all
right you know what I'm gonna get the
best [ __ ] turn up I had my eye on
this [ __ ] for so long it only cost
sixty five you know what I could buy
like more [ __ ] is it the scrump it's the
scrubs gasps yes oh my god I haven't
can't buy this no I can't [ __ ] like I
can unlock a dude and get ahead yeah I'm
doing that
Venetia with the partay see these head
Oh like Cuba dubstep
[Music]